obviously this is not something that you
just picked up you know because you're
bored like this is something you have
been doing for a long time like kind of
take us back how long have you been
making music or at least playing with
the thought of like rapping or writing
rhymes or just developing that
um
writing rhymes probably since like sixth
grade
making music and developing
what that was
that wasn't till
my freshman year of high school that i
started recording my homie and i wasn't
even like going to a studio my homie had
the uh so i'm at the crib yeah yeah the
the new mac the new uh mac computer and
with that new mac computer they had that
built-in mic
ah yeah learn how to garage van garage
band yep throw the headphones in and
then um
uh he would put the little blanket up to
cancel the noise
and i mean this just still didn't sound
all the way great but uh
we were selling mixtapes like i was in
high school selling mixtapes
um
along with other things but i would
package everything together and get it
out to you
and it was uh yeah it was a it was a
vibe man but it was getting that's when
i ate the weed and the mixtape
but it's like i know you gonna listen to
it now but